welcome everyone to chess and 21st
century actually I had something else
prepared for today there's an Indian
book Indian boy who's 11 years old who
just broke a record actually I think
he's 10 years old broke a record by
becoming the youngest I am in history
but the Grantchester started today so I
was watching the game so I thought this
guy's gonna have a long career so we can
come back to him later does anyone know
the grandchild stories right so it's a
tour so it's a bunch of tournaments so
it so there's Paris Belgium sinkhole
Cobb which is gonna be right here in
August no I was thinking when I know
where I am and London in December so the
rapids
so there's going to be two rapids
tournaments to blitz tournament doesn't
run though wrap it is yeah wrap it is a
faster so they're different times
control so when we play classical chest
it's the long one that goes on for six
hours blitz is only five minutes so it's
like the most fun one to watch and wrap
it is somewhere in between so like you
have time to think up in you bring your
games but not a lot so today was the
rapid portion so it was game 25 plus 10
second increment and increment means
every time you make a move you hit the
clog you get ten seconds more on your
clock so if you're really down on time
and you make a lot of moves really fast
you're going to get a lot of time on
your clock and then the game continues
so unlike in a blitz game where you're
trying to flag your opponent you cannot
do it when there's an increment so so
the tongue top ten players are playing
Magnus Carlsen Levin our own yawn we
have three Americans playing Fabiano
Nakamura and Wesley sob so you know a
lot of interest in the u.s. to watch
this because we have three Americans
playing so this game was between frozen
and karana so carbon is our current
year's champion present a is from France
I want to say so number two French
player so he was having a very bad
tournament up until this point he lost
the first two games and psychologically
it's very hard
when you're losing a lot of games to
recover from those games because you
know you're not feeling well and you
know you just have this mentality why am
I playing so bad but good chess players
are very good at recovering from their
bad losses so this game was very uh meat
yeah this is the game where a president
was up upon but it's a rook ending and
rook endings are always complicated it's
never I mean hardly ever just a
straightforward win especially when
there are other pawns on the board so
white sacrifices pawn on h3 there was a
white pawn to run the King to help this
pawn to promote oh good so black has
this past pawn white has this pass pawn
so who's playing for a win here white
because right because blacks King is not
completely useless and an endgame we
know how important the King is does
there's no keys to checkmate you so
you're supposed to use your king so here
mm-hmm
black played rook c3 so which way is the
king going there's a problem with going
to be fight so what are our other
options King b7 so if we want to promote
the pawn it doesn't make that much sense
with our King in front of it but we
still want the King to be close enough
so we can protect the pawn so d7 so we
have a plan of pushing and then if you
attack I can come close to my pawn so
let me show you so the problem with b5
is like if you go here so King g6
actually loses who can tell me why yeah
row k3 so you're now you're playing way
too slow here on you know I have counter
play if I didn't have the pawn then yes
you have all the time in the world you
can do whatever you want but I've
counter play upon that's about to Queen
so you can just take your time
forget about it so King to 7 so tag King
system so it doesn't make sense to go
back to c6 because check I've nowhere to
go so King c7 and now King b8 so now
again we're close to our pawn but we can
push our pot and we make our opponent
waste time so opponent pushes the way
push so now White has a very simple
threat King out and Queen
so what black plays very tricky plays
root K 3 so what to do so I have to say
I was very impressed by how white plate
is because first of all rock n games are
very tricky and they're playing rapid
which means they start with 25 minutes
and this is 150 so they had very little
time and with little time on your clock
to sit down and calculate something
precisely that's very impressive but
then again that's why they're the top
players in the world so you want to take
you don't care okay so you want to take
the rook so I get a Queen engage 7 so
now you're saying you're going to Queen
your pawn because I don't have checks
right okay so what else can I do
yeah so Quincy six possible between c1
is a temple move so Quincy one attacking
the rook so you don't have time to get a
queen because I'm going to take your
rook with a check so you have to move
your rook so question is where
yeah keep in mind you want to keep your
ruco a close to your King because if you
separate them and we checks I can take
it so either a five or a six so let's
try one so let's go a six and then
25 so what happens if you block a five
and then you cannot go back your rook is
hanging so now we're just repeating so
okay so what if this check I go here 25
and again it's going to be a drum if you
play here I'm just going to circle
around your King and you cannot get out
of this box so check to check so we're
just going to repeat the position
forever if you try ok 5 what can I do
now
yeah Quincy 3 Quincy 7 again attacking
this rogue and the problem is even if
you play here you're not threatening to
Quinn because of the pin so you cannot
make progress
so instead Roxy won again same idea if I
put my rook somewhere random let's say
okay this is not so random because I'm
talking but now I cannot win because
you're just going to keep checking and
you're going to keep harassing making so
the reason the route goes to C 1 and 8
or a1 is to block this file so my king
can get out without all this checks
so now Roxy 3 so now we have to figure
out what's the difference between taking
on a3 and CIN 3 and if that works so
Roxy dream so we have to consider it
taking because I mean okay White has
other ways to play but if you can find a
precisely you do precise calculation you
can calculate out your win then you win
the game so Roxy 3 and queen
so first of all what's the difference
between my rook being on scene see 3 or
a 3 yeah exactly so the difference is
Roxy 3 king c8 OOP sorry Queen in c8 the
first of all there is no check and if
they try to take your rope you can gain
a temple by checking so if they come
here because your rook on e3 was
restricted and now you have a check and
then next mome you can get a queen
so queen h8 was played when H drew was a
thread hmm what is black thread
community five right if we get a queen
here how it shows the move and then oops
so we don't want all of it
so rookie Trey I'll take on f2
the six I think removes you're going to
resign King the six I'll take this with
a check
so we need our King here to support this
pawn so you just need to make 25
impossible so you either have to move
your king or the problem with rook g3 is
if I take on f2 your rook is hanging so
your upper roof but your threat is to
get a queen if I get your rook then
you're not doing anything so you have to
hang on to your work so how else can we
stop 25 so that we have to move the King
or Roxy 5 so we take
so you cannot move your king if you move
your king I'll put a queen behind the
pawn you can not Queen just need to find
a good place with the rook rook c6 and
black pin doesn't have checks anymore if
Queen a7 can see eight and then if I
attack your rook again
rook season which is the whole point of
this whole line so again we ended up in
the same position we lost a pawn but
we're opera look so we don't really care
about that pawn it's the same it was the
same ideas here where are we yeah if
they attack our rogue we're going to
check on Quinn
so we just went around and wind it up in
the same place here check so check so
who can tell me why it's white we're
kidding right because you have increment
if you repeat the position so you don't
want to repeat the position three times
because you don't want to end up in
trying it accidentally but if you repeat
it twice you get 20 seconds on your
clock and when you have less than a
minute or two minutes 20 seconds is a
lot of time okay so let's see how we're
going to get out of this check so check
I would not recommend okay seven let's
try it okay seven oops
sound okay so so what if I check you so
you have to be careful precision so
what's your next move kind of block
right I'm going to check
you can get cannot get out of checks so
because if you put your king in a box
with nowhere to go so now my queen is
just going around
okay so here so what do we do so we have
to plug with the Queen
so Queen d5 so repeats again actually
here he repeats because after Queen a5
you can simply just go King v8 and he's
out of checks and you're threatening
mate
so queen month here so you need to use
the fact that these pawns are here and
they're kind of blocking the Queen so
the Queen cannot really yeah something
similar in the game so Queen here check
so the point of the Queen being here is
what now you're threatening checkmate
actually let me go move on with my move
if I want to fast so you're blogging
with the Queen so first of all let me
ask this question if I trade Queens and
take this pawn what's the easiest way to
win this
yeah okay fine smokes good - I was
thinking about rook c5 but rook air-five
also looks good again we want to keep
this king away from the pawns and our
King is very close so Roque face on
looks very good to me Roxy v also looks
very strong so check so we block now we
have a threat do you think the Queen
goes away of course black doesn't want
to trade we're going to meet so it takes
right we don't want to take and let the
king in or the log connected pawns our
king is close enough that it should be a
win but there's no reason and making
things complicated because the pawns are
separated our King is closed with an
extra rope so it should be a simple win
so King of 6 because if you take King g5
and if you try to push the pawn then my
rook is going to come and collect the
pawns
ok so King f6 okay so how I'm going to
win this so where do we need our rook so
when your opponent has passed pawns
where do you on your work behind the
pawn so you cannot come behind the pawn
because of the king so so if rook e7 I'm
going to take check in here so I'm not
sure you're even winning this because
now you're like your pieces are awkward
and your King cannot get in I'm going to
keep shouldering your king
so you don't want this to happen you're
the key is to keep to get your king in
and to keep this king away so how are we
going to get our look behind the pawns
okay
again simple okay fade because we don't
want the King coming and supporting the
pawns it could have also played King g5
one winning move changes in a corner
threatening mate and no way to start we
can't even go to engage for because I'll
check media yeah so he resigned here so
I thought this was a very great
calculation by frozen I'm it's
calculated the whole line out played
quite played very quickly very
confidently everything I quit and again
with a little time on your clock it's a
very hard thing to do and they suici
it's so easy to blunder a damn perpetual
in that position ok so I have two more
games I don't think we'll be able to
look at both of them so let me see which
one I want to pick so president beating
come on I was a bit upset because
president I was the lowest rated player
there are several upsets sitting Magnus
Carlsen actually flagged against Wesley
so yeah he did yeah he said he had two
moves he was picking between the two
winning moves and then he completely
lost about his time and actually he's
the one who looked at the time and said
oh I ran out of time and I I don't know
who was more surprised he more Wesley it
was just very strange because I was
watching itit Oh Magnus Queens and
Wesley resigned and then next thing I
know this is a no I mean he was like
really upset but like he came back to
shake his hand which I thought was
really nice and actually 2015 first
round of the Grantchester Magnus Carlsen
again Flags against Apollo in a
completely winning position is sitting
there calculating a win is unsure so
it's thinking thinking and then runs out
of time and loses Oh
so how he starts his tournament yeah he
won
you want three games in a row so did so
he should have had four and a half out
of five because the game was completely
winning in one move he could have ended
the game he won three games like after
he lost he beats Maxima telegraph like
he's playing a beginner almost you just
yeah he just crushed him so obviously
it's just playing well it just at the
bad luck okay so so it's a pile of car
on its Apollo is having a horrible
and and he hasn't been really playing
well lately I think he's either lost his
motivation or I don't know what's what's
up with him but of course it's still
advice from player he beat and he lost
three games in a row and then he beat
unleash Gary again it's very very tough
thing to do losing a lot of games
recovering from your losses it's so hard
to do especially for them the whole
world is watching and there's so much
ego involved as well alright so a4 a5 9f
396 is anyone familiar with this opening
scotch here so Knight f6 so what does
white do to protect the pawn don't say
Bishop d3 here yeah so if you move the
bishop model it's very unfortunate
because you block your queen so now your
nights hanging so what happens if you
play 93
so what opening is this
this is a scotch now gambit that means
you're giving self away definitely not
giving anything away here now so this is
the same opening as this right here
right here
so four nights stay playing for night so
if you're playing the Scotch you don't
necessarily want to play for night so
white takes a five so this is all
theorem
twenty-seven so there's a whole reason
behind this move and the reason is now
you you get this pin which is a major
line instead he goes night back and the
whole point is to see if this pawn only
five if it's going to be a strength for
white or a weakness that I'm going to be
able to eventually attack and get so
night out win here bring the bishop and
also putting pressure on the pawn 24 it
doesn't of course the white cannot
develop the bishop this way this pawn is
hanging so the Queen needs to move so
the bishop can get out and I was looking
at this position I was looking in the
database
the main move is to put the bishop on d3
so people don't really put the bishop
here so Bishop out let's defend the pawn
so this six
so why is white giving up this pawn
right there's a way why is the screening
of this function oh my god
I've been options I don't know 5:30
today so why is black giving up this one
so what happens if i take this pawn
right that would take only five so why
took one c7 but let's evaluate this
endgame so let's say take take and which
one do you want to take want to take the
C pawn so web two options we can take
the C pawn we can can't take the e pawn
I think both of them are fine but how
would we evaluate okay let's stay we'll
take this one for example how would we
evaluate this endgame how do you know
your positions good should you be
defending should you be playing for a
Wayne unless it's obvious you're
completely winning I gave an extra point
or something like how do you know okay
so there's a list of things we have to
look at right right so there's a lot of
things to consider and sometimes it
happens we've considered one thing and
we forget about everything else so a lot
of times it can be relative so for
example my a7 final is an isolated pawn
but are you ever going to attack this
pawn I mean not very likely right
because given where your pieces are and
where my pawn is like which piece is
going to come off the response so not so
relevant in this position so materials
equal the queens are gone so King safety
not so important right now so next we
move to the two pieces
so whose pieces are better why they're
stronger because I'm more active right
it should both bishops in the center
attacking all diagonals this is
attacking this is defending this is
attacking this is not even out yet so
it's not clear how white is going to
defend this pawn so I think taking on c4
is also fine for similar reasons I'm not
sure which one may be taking on e5 you
can just win the c-4 fun immediately
because I cannot push the pawn there's a
check hmm so why I decided to get greedy
and take this one so why did black
sacrifice upon why do we ever sacrifice
anything to get something well you don't
just because if you don't get anything
that's not sacrifice is just giving it
away so you need to get something so
what can we get in this position do we
have anything immediate which fun this
pawn yeah if you take that pawn you're a
little like helping me a little bit
because my bishop is not out and you're
just inviting my bishop into the game oh
yeah
all right that's true ah but here I can
throw in a move and now
yeah
what about one
okay so that's it so where is blocks
compensation with the spun-out for this
one
so which one of whites pieces is very
awkward and its place yeah the Queen so
so what other advantages does black have
right
right so you're heading development your
opponents are developed completely this
queen is really misplaced so you have a
lot of compensation but we want to do
something capitalize on it otherwise
it's going to take our opponents capital
moves to catch up there are different
kinds of advantages so if your advantage
is that you're ahead in development
that's very temporary because if your
opponent ketchup catches up and where's
your where is your advantage there are
more long-term advantages if your
opponent has an isolated pawn that's a
long term because that isolated fine is
always going to be isolated so if your
opponent is behind in development you
want to keep putting pressure to stop
your opponent from developing the pieces
so Bishop basic is very good idea and I
were trying to trap this queen and
there's also a practical point of view
so we can't always calculate the most
accurate move so we cannot figure
everything out in chess so it's good to
be practical so if it's easier for you
to play moves than the burden is on your
opponent to figure out what they're
doing so for black it's very easy to
play because all the pieces have very
natural squares to go to so Bishop is
attempt Bishop is attacking Knight is
attacking I'm threatening the Queen my
Bishop is open my queen is doing
something so all the flax pieces make
sense for white every move white has to
figure out how am I going to develop my
pieces how am I going to stop my
opponent from chopping my queen so
especially again in this faster time
controls you don't have the time to like
sit down think for like 20 minutes 30
minutes figure out the position so
you're kind of playing on instincts and
it's very easy for your instincts to go
wrong when you're in this kind of
situation so here white had to start
thinking about how to save this Queen
so how can we so I mean blacks position
is already really nice because c4 pawn
is a weight is weak this Queen is in
trouble so at least we're going to get a
pawn back so how I can White try to save
this quaint
we're usin bar
yes a but unfortunate thing about 25 is
you're also going to run into another
temple foxy eight so white needs to
start exchanging pieces to release this
kind of distension
because blacks pieces are very active
and white pieces are passive so of
course exchanges are going to benefit
white in general c5 so c5 two purposes
so attacking the bishop attacking the
knight creating square for my queen
so my black would have to take so now
move like Quincy for so your queen is
still not so comfortable and now we're
playing against this Bishop two because
this Knight stopping the bishop so this
pawn is going to be weak not clear how
are you going to save this pawn probably
you can you have to give it up so blacks
am white still has problems but at least
our Queen can run away maybe and at
least we managed to exchange some pieces
so we're not understood much pressure
instead so if you try to play Queen c5
yeah I'm simply going to take and now
I'm threatening this take the knight
take the bishop and then next if you
move then I'm going to play here then
now I'm actually winning upon and again
you're not developed and not exactly
sure where your pieces are going now
actually here maybe I can even play rook
t8 and threaten official before yeah
here Rock DHS wins the temple move
attacks the bishop threatens should be
four so Knight d5 was played so white
finds another way to try to release the
tension exchange pieces of course you
cannot take lose the bishop if you try
to defend the bishop okay first of all I
can take but even if I can't take then
I'm exchanging so I'm happy
but of course here you're losing
material again because your queen is
overworked
okay so 95 so what to do there's another
reason behind behind 95
can you play rook c8 and trap my queen
yeah so so you have to play this route
because this room just doesn't make
sense this pawn hangs so this rook now I
have a fork so white is really trying to
give this position together so what to
do so when I keep the pressure on so we
want to look at temple moves again right
so it takes up four so there's nerves so
if Knight f4 there's a line I'll show
you and then I'll explain the line to
you so Queenie for same idea is trying
to trap this Queen Bishop d4 is coming
so maybe you might even want to chase
this neither win win the bishop the
bishop goes to f3 so do we take the pawn
or do we throw in a check why
all the kings going to run away
and now we're going to take so what's
the difference between doing this and
this how does the king wink on each one
different than the king being on g1
exactly so in this position right so now
your rook is hanging and it's not
protected so if you take I'm going to
take so black of the white exchange
Queens the Queen didn't get trapped by
at least but again the position is very
tough this bishop is hanging this bishop
is a monster and it's going to be very
hard for Y to continue this development
of the pieces so instead Bishop d3 so if
luck just depends upon so I was talking
about in a different class like when is
it okay to make this kind of moves and
when is it not why is it okay to make
this move because usually we don't push
the pawns in front of our King who has
more control of the position boy
right because black is covering more
squares and black is covering key
squares I'm covering central squares so
it looks like whites pieces are aimed at
aiming at the King but they're kind of
scattered so this Bishop looks very
strong on the diagonal and looks like I
improved this bishop but this bishop
alone cannot check me because it's just
a bishop so the bishop needs a queen but
the queen is on c7 and there is no way
for the Queen to get on the diagonal
with the bishop to help the knight on d5
looks very nice but the knight on d5 is
cannot do anything to my King and it
looks nice but it's actually in reality
it's under attack and also we're
restricting our opponent's bishop and we
have this nice pawn chain and we're
giving our queen an extra square so
Quincy five
so actually the coin on c5 is not a good
square because
there's a potential problem
so which piece is it line up with right
so if we can make somehow bishop before
work we're going to win a coin
so our next move I think should be
obvious so rook the 8th so the knight
cannot let's say capture because these
are deform and black is a symbol threat
so if I pass the move to black simply
want to take nope
and everything's hanging so 97 so where
do we want to go with the Queen
mm how old places one for your queen
unsee it so I actually see eight it's
very dangerous
so see you might be in a lot of trouble
so what if I take defending my queen and
all of a sudden this Queen went from
doing nothing so yeah
ah so here Quincy ate so if I take you
still want to check that's where I don't
want to start sacrificing stuff like
take 1g5 where you want go Quinn up yeah
I might actually just play Quinn f5 not
there say threatening Bishop d4
the thing is a lot of moves that are
good so actually the move that car on
the plate wasn't even the best move but
cool but like why do you want to put
your queen on seat so question is your
Bishop on a6 it served the purpose but
it's not really doing much so it would
be much better if in the future your
Bishop could go here because it's going
to be on the longest diagonal i'ma get
this pawn so what would be the best
Square for the Queen
keeping in mind you're still threatening
Bishop d4 so your Bishop is not hanging
right so 24 is actually the best move
because you're threatening we should be
7 and if your opponent tries to trade
oops try sits right Queens okay so we
want a pond and we have this dominating
bishops still unclear where this guy's
going and also unclear so here I can
actually trap your night because you
have some background issues it's a la so
so even if we take the Queen's off it
doesn't really solve a lot of White's
problems because this development issue
it's just always there so instead he
played Queen eight six
so King runs away so bishop improves and
Bishop is under attack
so Queen f5 so what's white words peace
white okay rook on a1 but for not that's
likely so voice problems so this really
doesn't really miss please peaceful
white the night so you always have to
ask yourself questions to find moves
otherwise it's you're just looking at a
position and just pieces they don't make
sense so do so how do we attack this
round night in c6 a little bit
unfortunate I have to say otherwise
Quincy 60 every night whoa taste one oh
I see what you want do you want to take
me but so let's improve the peace and I
take a night 47 so multi-purpose move I
want to double my rooks and I'm
attacking your Nate so you went to five
so take take so this is this whole part
this was nothing fancy so I take your
night and now we want upon so we
improved our position so we want upon
our bishops are very strong like
fianchettoed bishops
so we have this little annoyance but our
queen is there defending there no other
piece can come and attack and our own
Bishop is very strong and this bishops
will move 23 in this bush Bishop hasn't
developed it the official final develops
but there is something awkward about the
bishop being there
right so there's two bishops on the D
file so let's do it with a temple
if route d8 the bishop still defend it
so from because the queen is defending
it so we have to chase the Queen away
Roxy fly right so always better to do
things with force your opponent doesn't
have time to defend now route t8
so what to do with white you're losing a
piece what happens if I go Queenie to
yeah cannot defend everything so if you
go rook aftering I'm simply going to go
back and you don't have rook here
because I just take and blocks pieces
just work so great together so okay so
what to do with white so we don't lose
the whole piece and this is a common
thing that happens in a game so if
you're going to lose a bit piece you
want to get some pawns for it or you
know you don't want to just lose a piece
for nothing you always want to have
something for it right it should be for
now block to move
okay 3-4 it's a question
what's wrong with luggage does Rakesh
your gumption same thing yeah
unfortunately this Bishop g1 so rach23
spins and it just like everything just
really came together in blacks position
I have five Ghana is where he when he
plays he plays like a machine like he
shows the stuff instantly so here like
on c5 looks very strong let's see if you
shop G to works
so you always want to press calculate
your force lines if those don't work
then you can go for something else but
if you have a forced wind then just end
the game so Bishop g2 kim jiwon keep in
mind now your rook is hanging right so
Bishop f3 and white resign okay so let's
see the line so here we're going to
check with on one of those our queen so
check
so we're threatening mate so he has to
take take and now we can count the ones
once we calculate a line the most
important thing is to evaluate the
position you want to make sure you
started UN you ended up better or at
least the same and where you start it so
you don't want to calculate a line on
your worse but you still plate so we
have a queen and Bishop one two three
four five against three pounds this is
hanging this is hanging King is still
weak so of course like it's completely
winning and at that level there's no
point of playing out the game so after
Bishop f3 I believe here is an idea so
it was a nice victory for Corona yeah so
this was a first of two ball of three
losses this is how it all started for
the follow but of course it was really
great to see Carlin and win such a
powerful game this tomorrow
so Friday Saturday Sunday they're
playing again so we have those games and
then we're going to have games again so
I mean the way they're playing obviously
we're going to get some more exciting
games and it's going to be blitz so it's
going to be much better with everything
hanging so thank you for coming to a
lecture